[Music]
i'm relaxed
and i get to this position okay
so above the elbow
tries that tendon of the insertion above
that
stick oh okay let's get there
okay so the drill to uh train
is not going is not to get there
that this is not the drill it's how you
got there
so here he dabbed me and then i went
there that's
going to be okay and then the same thing
keep going please did you see the
staccato stuff
that is too much pressure so here
not enough pressure and here
too much pressure okay it's just you
feel how relaxed i am
okay i want to be super soft
boom
so again it is super soft but uh push it
into me
push hard easy go up
go up push down on me you see
so i have to figure that out i can't
have
extension which is the size
tension do you get it so i'm super soft
boom but there's an integrity to the
motion
okay now let's try it again and i'm
looking
for gaps and
too much friction okay
if you're not sure what too much
friction is it's where you have to keep
adjusting you have to keep adjusting
because you got stopped
you see and then you got to let it go
again okay uh so imagine we're i'm
teaching you to drive and
you keep the car keeps going like that
i'm like
okay let's go come
come up with the cutting if you're going
here
up above it then below okay
this is the hard part so we probably
aren't gonna get it today
like he can push back at any time
you did push harder for sure not knock
me
i'll do it
okay is it muscle yeah you went
okay
you go and you push push
do you see
okay i just want you to be aware there's
a difference
okay so try it
see how you the hand comes the hand you
keep doing that
so it's basically like i'm going to draw
right
and i'm going to pass the line aside and
i
fish right or i'm going to pass the
holster
i draw and i come down below the holster
and i'm pulling
that that's what you're doing here so
instead of this hand coming over here
you're going like this okay
so you have to work on that extension is
not we don't
have we don't have extension we don't
use
extension in this jojo okay we have
integrity
we have organization it's different
extension
is tension okay so we come a little
closer
all right moving on he goes up i'm just
as light
and he's gonna come down when he reaches
the top he's gonna come
down boom
and i'm gonna move
we'll go slower same thing see how he's
slipping he's slipping
he's slipping he's slipping all right
and then you're gonna feel
you're gonna feel that rather than a
cave
or rather than stop it you're going to
redirection
this way when you redirect it you're
going to redirect it with the same
ip adhesion which is zero pressure
this way
okay let's try all right so again we
don't want to just do reps if you just
do reps
you're not learning okay so he goes
and uh look which drill am i doing
oh okay and then he comes down and i do
the second one
don't start going watch the distance
okay what's why is that over because
it's gonna cut this way do you see that
i'm in here like this right oh i hit
here
that's my intention i just decide not to
do that
so i have to be ready stand up
stand up push on me push on my hands
push on my hands
you see here look at look at the
difference
oh here so he goes
up boom you see here i don't
start doing something different okay he
comes around
this hand this hand
oh
[Music]
okay let's go don't lose the
integrity of your other hand even though
it's again so
he goes why don't go like this
see that oh yeah i'm gonna go like that
because
i'm gonna move out of the way oh
shoot you see this face i keep this face
do you see that if you can't see it come
on the other side
on he goes oh you guys are going like
this
crush then around
hold no crush
then start to get sensitive don't wait
to feel his pressure
feel his intention it starts to get
softer
okay let's go remember you're always
just doing those patterns
okay so he goes up right he comes down
look
you're not fighting his arm comes down
point
i'm not doing that i'm just doing the
patterns oh
because i need the kazushi pattern so i
need his spine to
tilt you see
this hand is pushing down here it's
going to yield
you see i'm going to not be there
but i'm not getting out of the way and
pushing it down
i'm sticking to it you think you're
going to keep bringing it
all the way around without cooking the
inside
so find the pattern of the inward spiral
boom okay try it again
i'm crunching down you guys are up here
and leaning
crunch down okay so his arm can't go any
lower right so he's going to pick it up
and i'm still stuck to it i step to it
i'm out here stuck to it and i want to
have
tension through his arm so what does
this look like when i don't
his arm moves his spine does not move so
from one point i should have not this
right i should have that
so that's our drill take the slack out
of the arm
okay don't worry about the throat
don't worry about putting ash
okay let's go
[Music]
he's tilting right and then this has to
not
wait slap slap slap this has to
keep him moving too
so i'm here it's not going to be in the
arms
[Music]
that's it okay so you come up i brought
it to the outside
right and i keep it going to the outside
i keep it going to the outside and
i do this in a way that i can feel the
tension
and not this slap so he's going i have
to feel the tension do you see
it's not grabbing it do you see just
those
energies this is slack feel the tension
okay so you all know what i mean by slop
all right okay if there's slack that guy
isn't gonna be where you think he's
gonna be
okay